COMMITTEE FOR MONEY PEOPLE
THIRTY IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE BE ADVISED ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDING WILL BE. MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS HAS ALSO
BEEN TELEVISED. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
CARE.
CUNNINGHAM.
CARILLO HERE CERVANTES HERE.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON. MAYES YEAR IS AREA.
PRESENT SOLACE.
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA.
MOVE. OVER INVESTORS AREA.
SECONDED BY.
MISS WALDRON.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER.
I GALLAGHER AYE GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE MAYES AYE.
MAYES I IN THIS AREA AND I IS
VERY HIGH SOLACE.
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
JOSEPH PENNA SUCH.
IT'S THE MOST HAS PASSED AND
THIS WAS A SLICE OF PIE THOUSAND
ALL WHICH ARE SOCIALLY INTERVIEW
VERY GOOD.
SOLACE. SOLACE I.
ISRAEL SWINGING DRIVE.
THANK YOU. HEROES OCCASIONS